desde el pasado jueves ha rescatado a
más de 200 migrantes en el mediterráneo
central incluyendo mujeres y niños pero
ahora la embarcación humanitaria
financiada por banks y dio a conocer que
se encuentra al máximo de su capacidad y
necesita ayuda inmediata ya hay una
persona muerta en el barco los otros
tienen quemaduras de combustible han
estado en el mar durante días y ahora
los han dejado solos en una zona de
rescate de la unión europea en louis
michel bautizado en honor a una
feminista francesa anarquista del siglo
19 decorado con obras del artista
británico ha emitido múltiples llamados
de emergencia italia malta o alemania-
sin recibir respuesta numeral louis
michel no puede moverse ya no es la
maestra de su maniobra debido a la
cubierta abarrotada y una balsa
salvavidas explicada a su lado pero
sobre todo debido a que europa ignora no
hasta llamadas de emergencia para
asistencia inmediata el artista
callejero vivo más conocido del mundo
pero cuya identidad se desconoce abordar
regularmente la crisis de la migración
en sus obras
el mediterráneo la ruta de emigración
más mortífera para quienes buscan llegar
a europa
las embarcaciones improvisadas se han
multiplicado en 2020 este año más de 300
migrantes han muerto en el intento de
cruzar